¿Saben lo que creía Aristóteles?
Aristóteles decía que
pensamos con el corazón
y que el cerebro solo se dedica a enfriar
la sangre que viene caliente del corazón
después de haber pensado.
¿No les parece una barbaridad
que una de las mentes más brillantes
de la historia de la humanidad
haya equiparado al cerebro
humano con un radiador?
Creo que todos estamos de acuerdo en que
Aristóteles esta vez estaba equivocado.
Hace más o menos 10 años investigo
la relación entre el corazón y el cerebro.
Básicamente la forma en que el corazón
produce enfermedades neurológicas
como los accidentes
cerebrovasculares o ACV,
y cómo el cerebro produce
enfermedades cardiológicas
como las arritmias.
Y en este camino de la investigación
me llevé un montón de sorpresas.
Eso de que pensamos
exclusivamente con el cerebro
y que el corazón solo bombea
sangre, no es tan así.
Por ejemplo, ¿cuántas veces les dijeron
que "decidan con el corazón"?
¿Qué tiene que ver esta bomba de puro
músculo con tomar una decisión?
¿O tal vez con las intuiciones
que es lo que necesitamos
para tomar decisiones, a veces?
Hay un estudio de la
Universidad de Cambridge
que revolucionó el tema
de decidir con el corazón.
Y abrió un camino enorme
en lo que nosotros llamamos:
"investigación sobre toma de decisiones".
En este estudio se les pidió a algunas
personas que participen de un juego
en el cual tenían que tomar decisiones
basadas en situaciones simuladas
en una computadora.
Y siempre había dos opciones
entre las cuales tenían que decidir:
una de ellas iba a tener un resultado
positivo o favorable,
y la otra iba a tener
un resultado desfavorable.
Y mientras participaban del juego
se les monitoreaba los latidos cardíacos
para saber cómo reaccionaba el corazón
justo antes de tomar una decisión.
Y lo que encontraron
los investigadores fue que
antes de tomar una decisión que iba
a tener un resultado favorable,
el corazón latía de una forma específica.
Pero cuando iban a tomar una decisión
que iba a tener un resultado negativo,
latía de una forma totalmente distinta.
Es decir que, aparentemente,
el corazón sabía antes de que
el cerebro fuera consciente,
si la decisión que se estaba por tomar
iba a tener un resultado
favorable o desfavorable.
Ahora les pido que se guarden
esto en la cabeza
y vamos a hacer un ejercicio nosotros,
vamos a experimentar con nuestro cuerpo.
Les voy a pedir que
cierren todos los ojos.
Todos cierren los ojos,
mantengamos silencio,
y pongan sus manos sobre las rodillas
hasta que yo les diga.
Y mientras hacemos esta prueba,
quiero que traten de ver si pueden
sentir sus latidos cardíacos.
Muy bien, abramos por favor los ojos.
Ahora les voy a pedir que levanten la mano
quienes hayan podido sentir sus latidos.
Perfecto, más o menos el 50 %.
Entre las personas
que levantaron las manos
probablemente haya muchos
que tienen desarrollada
una capacidad que se llama interocepción.
¿Qué es la interocepción?
Simplemente la capacidad de sentir
los mensajes que nos da nuestro cuerpo,
que nos envía nuestro cuerpo.
Como por ejemplo en este caso
los latidos cardíacos.
Volviendo al experimento
de la Universidad de Cambridge,
las personas que estaban
participando del juego
habían hecho exactamente
lo mismo que ustedes
y habían sido clasificadas
en quienes tenían buena interocepción,
o mala interocepción.
Y lo más interesante de
este experimento es que
quienes tenían buena interocepción tomaron
decisiones favorables más frecuentemente
que quienes no tenían buena interocepción
La conclusión de este
experimento parece ser
que quienes tienen la capacidad de
detectar, decodificar y procesar
los mensajes que nos manda
nuestro corazón antes de decidir,
aparentemente podrían tomar
mejores decisiones.
Por supuesto que, con todo experimento
revolucionario como este,
es necesario confirmarlo con otros
científicos que hagan la misma prueba.
Pero, mientras tanto, ¿no les parece que
no están tan mal algunas frases como
"escuchá tu corazón" o
"tengo una corazonada"
al momento de decidir?
¿Pero cómo hacen el corazón y el cerebro
para interactuar de esta manera
al momento de tomar una decisión?
Hay un área específica dentro del cerebro
que es el foco de nuestras investigaciones
que se llama ínsula.
Se llama ínsula porque es como una isla
que está debajo de la corteza cerebral,
oculta, y que está
hiperconectada con todo el cerebro.
Es como si fuera el gran aeropuerto local
a donde llegan y de donde se van
todas las conexiones
Pero la ínsula también está conectada
con otros órganos
como el corazón y el intestino,
entre otros,
y por lo tanto también es el gran
aeropuerto internacional
a donde llegan y de donde se van todas las
conexiones que están fuera del cerebro.
Y lo que tiene de interesante la ínsula
es que es pura neurona,
y el corazón es puro músculo.
Entonces ustedes me pueden decir:
¿cómo hacen para comunicarse
estos dos órganos tan distintos?
La respuesta es bastante sorprendente
porque el corazón, como el cerebro,
tiene neuronas.
Esos puntos blancos que ustedes ven
en el corazón son neuronas,
grupos de neuronas, a donde llegan
conexiones que vienen del cerebro.
Y eso que ustedes están viendo
es un típico corazón,
es la anatomía de un corazón.
¿Y qué pasó a lo largo de la humanidad
para que un corazón como ese
se transforme en el símbolo
universal del amor?
¿Qué tiene que ver el corazón
con amar o enamorarse?
En otro experimento, le pidieron
a algunas personas
que traigan fotos de alguien
a quien amaban profundamente,
y de alguien que les era
totalmente indiferente.
Y les hicieron una resonancia magnética
especial, que se llama funcional,
que nos permite ver qué áreas
del cerebro se están activando
ante determinados estímulos,
o determinadas acciones.
Y los que se vio en este
experimento es que
cuando las personas veían la foto
de la persona a quien amaban
se iluminaban áreas relacionadas
con el placer y con la recompensa.
Y no casualmente, una
de esas áreas era la ínsula.
La ínsula parece estar involucrada
en algunas funciones
junto con otras áreas del cerebro
que nos permiten darnos cuenta
que estamos enamorados de una persona.
Nos permite decir, "esa es la persona
de la cual yo estoy enamorado".
Y aparte, por sus conexiones
con el cerebro,
por sus conexiones con
el corazón y con el intestino,
hace que cuando estamos
con esa persona a quien amamos
tengamos taquicardia, palpitaciones,
y esa sensación de "mariposas" que a veces
se describe en el estómago
cuando estamos enamorados.
Entonces señores, nos enamoramos
con el cerebro y no con el corazón.
Y este grado de interconexión
que hay entre el cerebro
y que tenemos también con la ínsula,
hace que tenga repercusiones funcionales,
pero que también haya repercusiones
que pueden resultar en problemas de salud.
Por ejemplo, les quiero mostrar
en este gráfico:
acá tienen en el eje horizontal
los meses de mayo, junio y julio.
Y en el eje vertical,
tienen la cantidad de infartos cardíacos
que hubo en la ciudad de Múnich.
En el año 2003, la cantidad de infartos
en esos tres meses se mantuvo constante,
no hubo cambios.
Año 2005, pasó algo similar.
Año 2006, mayo, sigue todo igual;
junio y julio explota
el número de infartos en Múnich.
¿Qué pasó?
Muy bien, muchos de ustedes ya se dieron
cuenta y es el Mundial de Fútbol 2006.
(Risas)
Y cada partido que jugó Alemania,
es uno de los picos que ustedes
están viendo en la diapositiva.
Y más interesante todavía,
es que el pico número 5
es el partido por cuartos de final
que jugó Alemania con Argentina
y que prefiero no decir cómo terminó.
(Risas)
Ese partido lo estaba viendo un amigo
que se llama Hans en su casa.
Hans estaba sentado frente al televisor,
y se pasó viendo primero y segundo tiempo
que terminaron empatados
y toda la definición por penales.
Estaba ganando Alemania 4 a 2,
faltaba el último penal,
Cambiasso se prepara para patear
y está Lehmann en el arco de Alemania.
Patea Cambiasso, ataja Lehmann,
clasifica Alemania,
y Hans que es el equivalente alemán
del Tano Pasmann,
(Risas)
pega el grito de su vida, libera toda la
energía y toda la adrenalina
que acumuló durante esos 90 minutos
más los penales,
y en cuanto terminó de gritar
la atajada del penal
fue a parar directo al hospital
con un infarto.
Como muchos otros alemanes
ese día en el que se triplicó
el número de infartos en la ciudad.
Hans es un ejemplo viviente
de cómo algunas emociones
que afectan nuestro cerebro
hacen que en forma transitiva
terminemos teniendo un problema cardíaco.
El estrés que tuvo Hans,
esa sobredosis de adrenalina
terminó comprometiendo al corazón
y produciendo el infarto.
Entonces, uno acá se plantea
¿tenemos que resignarnos
y aceptar que estamos expuestos
a lo que este sistema tan complejo
corazón-cerebro nos expone
en cuanto a nuestras emociones?
¿O hay algo que podamos hacer?
La ciencia nos está abriendo muchas puertas,
una de ellas es a técnicas milenarias.
Técnicas que, por más que tengan
miles y miles de años,
solo se han investigado seria
e intensivamente en los últimos años.
Y una de ellas, es el "mindfulness".
Mindfulness es una especie
de técnica de meditación
que nos permite concentrarnos
en todo lo que está pasando alrededor,
en las sensaciones, en las emociones,
y en los mensajes de nuestro cuerpo.
¿Les suena esto de
mensajes de nuestro cuerpo?
¿Interocepción?
Cuando me hablaban de mindfulness
hace unos 10 o 12 años,
yo era absolutamente incrédulo
porque, por supuesto,
no había ninguna
evidencia científica, nada.
Y como solemos pensar con
una mente médica y científica,
lo que no sea probado, no sirve.
Entonces miren lo que pasó
en los últimos 10 años.
2005 a 2015:
publicaciones científicas que en el título
tienen la palabra "mindfulness".
Aumentaron enormemente,
y gran parte de ellas,
la parte más importante de todas
estas publicaciones que están viendo
investiga la utilidad del mindfulness
para combatir cosas como el estrés.
Yo sé que ustedes son escépticos
que tienen una mente curiosa
y que no se van a creer cualquier cosa
que les esté diciendo.
Entonces vamos a jugar a que
ustedes son los científicos,
y les pido que piensen qué
situación estresante podríamos usar
para comprobar si el mindfulness es útil
o no es útil para combatir el estrés.
¿Cuál es la peor de las situaciones?
La guerra.
En California hay un centro
donde los marines son entrenados
antes de ser enviados al campo de batalla.
Es el último entrenamiento
donde se hace un simulacro
súper estresante
en el cual los Marines están enfrentados
a soldados que tienen la fisonomía
de quienes van a enfrentar.
Los ruidos son los mismos,
los olores son los mismos,
y descripto por ellos mismos,
es el momento más estresante
antes de ir a la guerra.
En este centro de entrenamiento,
se tomó a la mitad de los marines y se
les ofreció hacer mindfulness 8 semanas.
Y al resto, la vida de siempre.
Hicieron el mindfulness,
se sometieron a este terrible simulacro,
y después del simulacro
se les hizo un cuestionario
en el cual se les pregunta
cuán estresados estaban.
Y lo interesante es que quienes
habían hecho mindfulness,
estaban mucho menos estresados
que quienes no habían hecho.
Ustedes me pueden decir,
"claro, esto es sugestión...
"...porque como hicieron mindfulness
van a decir que tienen menos estrés".
Pero también se les midió en sangre
una proteína que libera el cerebro
ante situaciones de extremado
o extremo estrés.
Y los Marines que habían hecho mindfulness
tenían niveles muchísimo más bajos
que quienes no lo habían hecho.
O sea que hay una demostración
subjetiva y objetiva
de que algo podemos hacer
para disminuir el estrés.
Y como este hay muchos otros experimentos
que son los que muestra este gráfico.
Entonces, pareciera que gracias a cosas
que existen hace mucho tiempo
y que la ciencia está mostrando ahora,
tal vez tengamos la posibilidad de
disminuir el impacto de algunas emociones
sobre nuestra salud
y sobre el sistema corazón-cerebro.
Y tal vez en el futuro,
esto lo dirá la ciencia,
hasta se puedan prevenir enfermedades
como el ACV o infartos cardíacos,
usando este tipo de técnicas.
Por ahora creo que todos tenemos que
reconocer al genio de Aristóteles
que fue el primero en pensar
que el corazón y el cerebro
funcionan como sistema.
Y creo que también es bueno recordar
las palabras de un gran sabio que dijo,
"un buen corazón y un buen cerebro,
son una combinación formidable".
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)